hey guys I'm the real rejects with me as
the other real reject we're gonna watch
the trailer today for this movie called
chips brand-new original concept never
been done before
people are excited that finally
Hollywood is doing original ideas and
they can not be more enthused this is a
big deal for me I grew up watching chips
this is a hard-hitting drama as a child
as a boy punch in genre my vintage just
like uh you know it's a hard-hitting
drama it's in the vein of films like
Copland
yeah we're Miami Vice by Michael Mann
I'm a vice
I believe Michael Mann's producing this
film is really yeah this should be a
really gritty dark original drama shot
all Han Hill it's gonna be super
handheld no comedy just like the show
cam I own bit by saying that better hold
it we're the California Highway Patrol
without us out there oh thank god how
did he know we're gonna watch
we're the California Highway Patrol
this job is crucial without us out there
California Highway Patrol think they
have some crooked cops we want you to go
on the inside
go on the cover within the department
that's awesome we look you with a rookie
named Jon Baker
tell my plan francis llewellyn
poncherello are the first two female
names john here many of the husband he
is really handsome you've had 23
surgeries you can ride a motorcycle I'll
give you that yes ma'am
like a mother here mm-hmm what's up I'm
John Petrella awesome man we're partners
let's kick this off with the real name
Oh
- Carole move over for whatever that's
cool no no no no no no Baker Baker Oh
literally badass you know suited up the
battle for looking like UPS drivers
super cool go Brown
this job is my one shot it saved me my
marriage what are you wearing my uniform
Oh reveres too intimate all moto
motorcycle car I got no emotion what's
your job fine 230 cops
you're FBI so if we need to focus
are you kidding me right now I'm just
like powerless when it comes to yoga
pants let's get you out of this park now
you have a visible erection you think
you can ride with that I don't know we
don't know who in this department is in
on this we're like jay-z and Beyonce
we're a ride-or-die
I'm jay-z you screw up this taste your
fight you've got a legitimate lead oh we
have a suspects head as a victory nasty
I was just
damn nasty I need to get into some warm
water my gonna kill you there I saved
your life with you then you you're gonna
bring it up where me do with dick jokes
you faceplant in my town oh there's no
content that could have swore I felt
either your nose or your lips
I've been like a little bit of contact
Wow Channing Tatum and Jonah Hill have
never been higher
oh good you goody Wow um yeah you know I
gotta say huh Hollywood oh this is it
has so many thoughts like Sohni emotions
you see a few out really quick nice good
a few thoughts and emotions out really
quick take it poncherello all right okay
might be funny yeah okay it might be
funny could be it could it could it
could definitely work I could see how it
could work you got a great cast of
characters in here
Dax Shepard Michael Pena it's cool to
see Michael Pena honing in on those
comedy skills some more cuz he was like
a hug he was he was like the highlight
for me and ant-man I always really
enjoyed seeing yeah he's a great
dramatic actor hands down but it's cool
to see him doing comedy like a straight
up comedy you know you see Vincent
D'Onofrio make cameo in the in this
trailer watch I come on John gets into
the trailer Kristen Bell is you know Dax
Shepard real life life so yeah that's
really funny I love that when that
happens you got some funny bits bromance
and partners don't really get along gay
jokes cuz they're guys they're straight
and then you know Oh penises yeah I'll
get that on your felt I gotta say I mean
if they make that joke they can make
that joke work if it's like a
reoccurring bit of Michael Pena like
really going I'm totally cool with gay
guys I'm totally cool with gay stuff but
he keeps getting engaged at could be
that's where I think it could be funny
if they play that right cuz there's a
lot of that in this trailer yeah there's
a surprising amount of like alike a
dude centric humor yeah yeah dude
centric humor Michael Pena not being a
homophobe but he kind of is a little
homophobic you know yeah I feel like you
know we're coasting now he was clearly a
plug-in play I mean it's got the Super
Troopers meets me let's [ __ ] it's 21
Jump Street his jobs really a formula
and we've precedent yeah parts of the
studio's said 21 Jump Street was awesome
that they rebooted it and made it a
full-blown comedy
action-comedy you know that was
self-aware or referential and has
bromance humor in it and now then they
got a watch and then I got chips now I
just can't help but we are coasting
can't help but see that let's get
another old lady shot damn this is this
is the new one this idea for bewitched
it's gonna be great this cuz 21 Jump
Street work now they're really trying to
hone in on this I don't know
because bay watches the is the next film
that has been inspired by the 21 Jump
Street reboot we don't know if that
works yet hmm so if that works then I
might come back to another trailer of
this and go well maybe chips is gonna be
great then Jump Street sets the bar high
Jump Street says yeah jump streets
clever yeah and 22 is really funny as
[ __ ] 222 some people think that's better
the Jump Street movies earn their
raunchy humor by being more clever and
more heartfelt than you expect them to
be I don't necessarily get that from
that like I like these people
and I'm even okay with the concept even
though like you know I saw enough chips
no this isn't the chips that IRA man
honestly like just this I didn't think
this was a very good
I don't remember chips at all what I do
remember is we went to st. Charles and
Erik Estrada loved to go to st. John
he's did he'd love to go to the
carnivals Erik Estrada felt like he was
a superstar again when he went to the
st. Charles events yeah yeah yeah so
that's a lot remember from Suzanne I
remember it being like a light-hearted
drama yeah it wasn't like necessarily a
comedy and it wasn't heavy hard-hitting
drama it was just enough of both to run
during the daytime now you don't need to
redo chips and make it exactly like the
show I'm totally okay with that gritty
violent it's just super bliss just in
terms of marketing it's it's a little
distracting when you see them go let's
remake chips into 21 Jump Street huh
yeah exactly
it's the only thing that's distracting
about it did some of the jokes land sure
about some of the jokes were pretty
funny
I think Dax Shepard is really funny yeah
I rarely find him funny in trailers when
I watch the actual movies he's in I
think he's hysterical yeah he's got some
and Michael Pena too so this movie will
really fall on the chemistry of Michael
Pena and Dax Shepard yeah so I feel like
as long as that's great I feel like we
can
get a fantastic time at least maybe it
won't be a magical this 21 junkie and
[ __ ] you if you dramatic me for compared
to 21 Jump Street [ __ ] deadly like
someone told totally calls for it yeah
the the pitch for this start was started
with 21 Jump Street worked yeah
Lyon ships was about cops too and I do
the exact same thing I'm like it was
chipped Michael was Erik Estrada's
character undercover I don't remember
that part I thought they were just too
regular they were just too Highway
Patrol masters I think that would have
been way funnier yeah I mean like
honestly I'm a super troopers even funny
yeah yeah but more ago more that will
Ferrell side of the spectrum yeah like
yeah like the other guy is kind of a
territory like they're like you got the
cops you got all these like heavy
hitters in LA yeah then you got
California Highway Patrol which is
usually dealing with a lot of traffic
maybe that's why they did that is to
make it different from 21 Jump Street
because like you know it almost feels
like they split the difference in what
okay we're gonna kind of make the stakes
higher and make this more serious but
also we're gonna make this also much
more wacky yeah that FBI thing I don't
know if I never remembered that and I
don't I don't it seems to be a very
beautiful or video kill it seems to be
super important to this plot is what's
gonna happen next
when they do a sequel I'm not gonna go
into cover anymore I want to commit to
be house for the Highway Patrol officer
I'll leave it my job all those benefits
yeah right now in this current mode I'm
in hell when I go to the movie I'm gonna
be like I just want to laugh and have a
good time and I be hope to this he's
super content with that it's good I
didn't even know this movie was getting
made I didn't - I had no idea they were
doing chips reboot just got a comment
about it and I was like what the [ __ ]
they're gonna chips movie that's already
shot I saw a musical based on chips once
no that's what this should have been
chips miu-sama Neil Patrick Harris yeah
listen you can subscribe to the real
rejects for nothing but positivity over
here John is reasons to Jerry on Twitter
and Instagram he's also the social media
manager blum house is Facebook and the
real rejects is Facebook and Blum
calm all right guys what do you think of
the chips trailer are you excited for it
you love that that old show you set for
Erica star to come in and do a cameo and
promote insurance are you safe which
company I don't know he did a lot of
infomercials